This strip, in Cape Town,
South Africa,
divides the beachside community of Strand
from the township of Nomzamo.
They're only a few meters apart. But the
people on each side live very different lives.
Strand has backyards and driveways.
Nomzamo is much more dense.
And the people here
have fewer basic services:
Less piped water.
Less internet access.
And Nomzamo is majority Black,
while the area across the line is majority white.
If we use dots on a map to represent race,
you cansee how stark that divide is.
If we zoom out to the whole city,
we can see it's actually everywhere.
And this is the case
across much of South Africa.
The color of your skin here
often determines whereyou live.
It also determines
your quality of life.
This map shows where jobs and opportunities
are primarily concentrated in Cape Town.
And this is where most of
the city's Blackpeople live,
in informal settlements called "townships"
on the city's periphery.
"Peoplehave to move by public transport
forup to three hours a day,
and they can't take careof
their obligations in the community,
with therest of their family,
because they're alwaysworking
and they're always traveling."
For decades, South Africa
was under apartheid:
a system that wrote
segregation into law.
A white minority controlled where
non-white people could live,work, exist.
Many were forced out of their homes.
In 1994, a democratically elected government
tookpower, and ended apartheid.
It was supposed to bea new beginning.
But a lot of thecountry still looks like this.
And that's because South Africa's legacy
of racial division goes back centuries.
In the 1600s, the Dutch took over
the southerntip of Africa,
to supply ships with food
along the trade route to Asia.
150 years later, Britain seizedit,
and named it "Cape Colony."
Many Dutch colonists
moved here, further inland,
to escape Britishrule and
continue exploiting enslaved people.
Just like the Dutch, the British used CapeColony
as a strategic location for trade;
it wasn't economically significant.
But in the 1870s, that changed, when
the British started mining diamonds there.
Suddenly, Cape Colony was one of Britain's
mostprized and exploited colonies.
In order to get thediamonds
out of the country, they built railways,
to connect the mines up here
to the coast.
The railways allowed the British
to access a globaldiamond market
through the port city of Cape Town.
Soon, the economy of Cape Colony
was centeredaround the railroads.
Especially this main route.
The green areas on this map show
the Blackregions of Cape Colony,
largely left out
of the railroad economy.
Racial inequality inCape Colony
was being reinforced by location.
To keep it that way, the colonial government
started writing segregation into law.
The Natives Land Act of 1913
pushed Black people into these areas:
only eight percent of South Africa's land;
and restricted them from
owning land everywhere else;
or, relocated them to the edges of
the major cities, to work for whitepeople.
These laws began to shape the region.
Cape Town's growth from the increased trade
turned the port town into a major city.
Many migrants from the rest of the
colony, and elsewhere, moved here,
to whatwas then the
outskirts of Cape Town,
whereformer enslaved people,
merchants, artists,and immigrants,
were forming a neighborhood
calledDistrict Six.
As the city grew around District Six,
so did the neighborhood.
For decades, DistrictSix was
a thriving, integrated community.
"We were a very cosmopolitan,
you could sayfamily, almost.
Because there were people
from all different nationalities,
from all different walks of life."
"This was the statement:
Your childis my child."
But it wouldn't last.
In 1934, Britain's legal hold in whatwas now
the Union of South Africaofficially ended.
The remaining white minority, the descendants
of Dutch colonists, took control.
And they built on the foundation
the British were leaving behind.
Between 1949 and 1971,
the all-white governmentpassed
148 laws solidifying apartheid.
"Apartheid allowed for the
full realization of the ambition
of the fascist project
in South Africa."
In 1950, the Population Registration Act
officially classified people by race:
white, colored, and native (or Black).
And eventually, Asian.
Then they made lawssaying
where people could live.
Around the country,Black South Africans
were moved into these areas,
called homelands, or "bantustans."
Bantustans were rural areas
and had underdeveloped economies.
Manyof them were in the areas Britain had
already excluded from the railway economy,
and where Blackland ownership
had been restricted to.
Black peoplewere forced
to carry "pass books,"
that specifiedwhere they
were allowed to work or travel to.
In cities like Cape Town, the "Group Areas Act"
movedthe remaining non-whites
into separate urban areas.
"The most prime land, and the land
closest to higher-valued property,
was allocated to white people."
In 1966, the government declared that
DistrictSix was now a whites-only area.
The residentsof District Six received
removal letters likethis one,
that said living there was illegal,
because they were not white.
Bulldozers droveinto District Six,
and razed it to the ground.
"We lived here. We had a life here."
"It was very traumatic for a lot of people."
"It's like ripping out someone's heart."
More than 60,000 people were
forcibly removed from their homes.
This kind of violence against non-white people
was commonplace around the country.
But, after decades of pressure,
both from within South Africaand abroad,
apartheid rule finally came to an end.
The new government lifted restrictions
on where people could live.
Millions of people, who had beenexcluded
from economic developmentfor centuries,
migrated to major cities, lookingfor
basic services and economic opportunity.
"For any family with
no prospect of employment,
themost rational, logical choice to make
is to migrateto an urban center."
They settled where there wasempty land,
creating townships on the peripheries
of major cities like Cape Town.
The governmentbuilt millions of homes,
and expanded clean waterand electricity.
"But it had a number of unforeseen consequences,
the most important of whichis that
the only land that could beused for the public
housing programwas on the periphery of the city.
And for thatreason, a brilliant intention
to overcome the apartheid legacy
unintentionally reproducedthe very
same legacy it was trying to undo."
Today, 60% of the mostly Black
populationof Cape Town
lives in these townships
at the edge of the city.
The thing is, Cape Town's City Center
has land to develop.
But because of its location, it's valuable,
so it usually gets sold to private
developers, who build luxury apartments.
Nearly abillion dollars worth of them
are going upby the coast.
But, right in the heart of CapeTown,
by all the expensive developments,
District Six remains largely untouched.
The former residents have fought
against privatedevelopment,
and they've actually succeeded.
Some have even managed to return
to housesbuilt by the city.
"I wanted to come backhere,
where I was born,
which was part of
our family's heritage."
"I couldn't believe that I was back.
It was a sense of relief."
But there are still hundreds of claimants
waitingto get back to District Six.
"We haven't done the difficult
and the painful work
to confrontwhat the
intergenerational consequences are
of colonialism. Of apartheid."
The story of Cape Townand South Africa's
racial segregation starts far in the past.
But it's very much entangled
with thepresent.
Apartheid and colonialism here are over.
But many of the barriers theybuilt
have yet to be dismantled.
"The kind of psychic scars that's left
on individuals and on communities.
We haven't begun the work of saying, How do
welive together, in the face of that history?"